- I did a lot of weird,
I like sold Time Life
books over the phone.
I sold steaks.
- Steaks, Omaha steaks?
- Omaha steaks is where I worked, yeah.
It would be a lot of me.
- Is that like, how do you sell that?
Mine was easier.
- I would call and my main
thing, it's so stupid,
I would take a piece of paper
and this was like my closer,
I would wiggle the piece of
paper in front of my face,
which is where the headset was,
and then I go, sorry, excuse
me, my manager's here.
What's that?
No, I can't, really?
No.
What?
And then I get back and
I'm like, I'm so sorry,
I can't believe this is happening,
but this just came in from upstairs.
One floor building.
This came in from upstairs,
we're gonna cut the price
of those filets by half.
(laughing)
I can't believe we're doing this!
And then people are like,
everyone wants a deal.